so do you have a favorite animal
i would say snakes snakes okay those are
your favorites
why snakes yeah i just love snakes man
why snakes you know i i read the bible
as a kid and i remember thinking like
adam and eve and my name's adam and you
know i'm kind of into the eve thing and
the snake and the apple i was like i was
like
so so from a kid i'm like oh these
snakes and now i'm like and then i saw
indiana jones that was a whole disaster
yeah but so why snakes because they're
pretty scary i got my first snake at
four so i mean like my own personal
snake i was catching them before that
you know but i was just always intrigued
by their movements you know i would see
a worm and like a worm moves a little
slow but i saw a snake one day and it
moved so fast and i was like wow
i want to touch it
you know like i want to touch it oh it's
like that i want to touch it i want to
touch it i love snakes so much one day i
was a kid and i saw a dead rat and their
tail looks like a snake but it was like
underneath some stuff so i pulled his
tail thinking it's a snake and i pull a
dead rat off the side of the street and
i'm like oh man you know i'm like well
that's cool because snakes eat rats you
know so did you slightly freak out when
you you had a dead rat in your head i
thought it was a snake you know but i
was just a kid you know it could have
been a stick i picked up sticks thinking
they're snakes and everything in my head
is when i was hoping for a snake end up
with a dead rat yeah you know that was
my childhood favorite animal is a snake
yeah ladies do you have a favorite
animal um if you could own any animal
we're not talking spirit animal we're
just we're going to get to that in a
second favorite animal dolphin for sure
dolphin miami miami dolphins yeah but
they're just super smart and they're
empathetic and um
yeah the way they communicate and the
way they they're loyal they travel in
packs
they also masturbate
are you familiar with that do dolphins
actually masturbate
how does that a lot of animals
masturbate
oh who why when i get that animals have
sex hello you know hormones man you know
so dolphins are out there being like oh
but how is this proven i
used that scientifically yeah they use
the coral
yeah well that's interesting it's funny
did you do not believe the animal expert
no no i'll take you out there with some
dolphins i'm just saying you're going to
end up with donkey stuff all the time
you don't need that in your life
what kind of what's your favorite animal
um my favorite i would have to say
elephant elephant yeah
i don't have a reason why i think just
without them we cannot survive in our
ecosystem right i mean just like with
any other animal as well
um
sharks are and so on but yes i would
have to say definitely elephant
but funny story
with snakes that used to be my biggest
fear ever right until two years ago i
was in peru
sitting um on this you know just doing
plant medicine and i was on ayahuasca
and when i tell you about you were on
ios
but no just laying down on the um you
know the floor or on the grass because
you do it well at least where i was i
did it in a forest right so
i could hear any
and every animal there existed right
because i was outside
connected to nature and what not
and i just turn around and i see a snake
right next to me and i'm telling you
this is not because i was on medicine
even when you're on medicine you're
conscious you're fully aware of
everything that's happening right
and the snake was just chilling there
with me and i saw it and i touched it
and i was like wow this snake is so
beautiful so anyway since then i've
never been afraid of snakes everywhere
wow yeah what's ayahuasca yeah it was
and what's your favorite animal oh
i think my favorite animal is also my
spirit animal and that is a monkey slash
chimpanzee gorilla i can go from like
you know like that manly gorilla dude to
like more of a playful monkey but it's
somewhere in the ape species although
shout out to valuetainment i'm rocking
the king of the jungle the lion today
this is our you know our brand
you